you've had a night to sleep on it um i
know you're a guy that
respects the game very much and uh last
night
when you took out jalen uh in a close
game i think you're aware that it sent a
message kind of
across the league i think fan eagle fans
were upset about it but i think football
fans were upset about
what it said um can you speak to that
now that you've slept on it a little bit
about um
you know the message that maybe did that
sent and the perception that people had
about the way that the game panned out
you know i i've thought about that quite
a bit and um
uh you know quite frankly i look at the
entire body of work i look at the entire
season and it's definitely not the
season that we all had anticipated and
you know our our offensive struggles
have have not been about
you know one one position group or or
one guy or
you know uh whatever it's it's it's been
it's been a a multi multitude of of
issues that we've had and
and and again last night in that game
you know we were in a situation where we
we
we failed to score as an offense we
failed to score there at the end of the
third quarter we were we were struggling
just a little bit to move the ball
defensively they kept us kept us in the
game with a couple of takeaways late and
and and my plan was to was to get nate
in the game nate nate's
nate's a guy that that is very capable
of of running our system and executing
in
an opportunity to to to pull that game
out last night and
there's the headline in the washington
post sports section
tanks for everything and in philly
they're saying thanks for
nothing but uh i said it this morning
i'm gonna say it now
doug peterson after the game and
this morning both came off as a guy who
is delivering
a speech that he has rehearsed in
the mirror repeatedly because i just
don't buy it
he's saying what he thinks he has to say
he didn't even answer the question he
eventually kind of got around
to it but he didn't get into any of the
nitty-gritty of this perception that
they deliberately
and intentionally chose to lose the game
that's what they did and if they didn't
they should be offended they should be
on the offensive not the defensive they
should be
loud they should be in your face they
should be yelling and screaming and
sending out statements denying that they
would ever
undermine the integrity of the game the
mere fact that they're not reacting that
way shireen
tells me they did it they knew what they
were doing now
fundamentally look i was upset last
night about it
primarily because i was upset with
myself
for not seeing that it was coming i
allowed myself to buy into the hype of
game 256 and it's a special game and
you're going to go out there and you're
going to play hard
and and you know we're going to have the
highest level of regular season
competition it's a playoff
play in game and it it it
never occurred to me it was stuck in the
blind spot
on on each side mirror for me that
that the eagles were going to say well
you know what screw it we'd rather have
the sixth overall pick than the ninth
overall pick that's what i'm upset about
because i get it i've been saying for
years
who ca who cares about the difference
between five ten and one and four eleven
and one who cares
that that that gives you nothing getting
the sixth overall pick
gives you something well and mike
i think they would have lost anyway i
don't think they were going to win that
game i mean washington kept trying to
give it to him
obviously but it didn't work and and i
do think they
eventually would have lost i don't feel
sorry for the giants i mean win more
games this is a horrible division they
shouldn't even
division chief it shouldn't even be
going on in the postseason but
washington ended up being
the best team in the division and i
think if you have to have one of those
teams go then it was definitely
washington so i don't feel
any sadness for for the giants at all go
win more games is
is what i would say to new york giants
today but
i keep going back to and i watched it
last night
the the jason kelsey video from december
from the middle of december
when he talked about winning and the
integrity of the game and that's what
you do you go out you play
the game to win and i'm just wondering
how you go back in that locker room as a
coach
and you try to sell to your team that
that's not what we did and we're looking
to the future of the franchise and all
those sorts of things i just don't know
how you build that
back within your team and i think going
forward this could be a problem uh
within that locker room of those guys
who are there again
next year that's what i was told by
somebody who's been involved in the nfl
for over 30 years last night that
it makes sense to do it but you lose
something culturally when you actually
do it and it's one thing for a team that
is in position to get the first overall
pick
to suddenly decide we are going to do
our best to grab that brass ring by
falling off of the horse and blowing
a double-digit second half lead like the
buccaneers did week 17 in 2014
when they were up 20-7 in the fourth
quarter pulled half their starters and
lost the game and got the rights to
jameis winston
i guess that was the punishment from a
karma standpoint
the jameis winston five years in tampa
but
it's one thing to do that when you have
a team that's going to be gutted anyway
this is an eagles team that just
the way they would tell it needs a
retooling well now you've got to rebuild
your credibility with those veteran
players that
are wondering why why what are we doing
here
why you know and again it's the it's the
setting
it's that game 256. it's
it's a game that has direct relevance to
washington and the giants and we were
led to believe just by the circumstances
the giants and the cowboys have the
elimination game at one o'clock eastern
well that game ultimately means nothing
if
philadelphia isn't going to try to beat
washington and i think that's what made
football fans upset
we were led to believe that last night's
game was going to mean something
all the way through and then when all of
a sudden it didn't i remember getting
the text message from you because i was
up here in the studio
and we had just done a digital
discussion with tony dungy rodney
harrison mike tarico
and we saw on the monitor just as we
finished
the fourth and goal play and we were
trying to figure out why they would go
for it fourth and goal
down 17-14 and tony said well i guess
it's the analytics telling you got to go
for it there instead of taking the tie
and we
we couldn't process it and i got the
text message from you oh my god i can't
believe
they're going to put nate sudfeld in the
game and i was flabbergasted
and and again i was upset with myself at
the end of the day because i didn't see
it coming it makes sense
i don't think anybody saw it coming last
night including the nfl i mean moving
forward the lesson to be learned by the
nfl is
when you're picking that game just
because you found the one game
that on paper has playoff ramifications
that survive the other
15 you better be damn sure that the
other team has something to play for
because the same thing could happen uh
in the future
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports